Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. This is gonna be my Agents of SHIELD episode 11 video.
We got to meet a couple new characters so I'll try to explain who they are,
some people from the comics, some people not from the comics. The back half of the
season is going to slowly introduce the
idea of
Inhumans to the Marvel Universe which
is a really big deal. It's huge that Marvel
is letting their TV division introduce
this but the movie so far away they
probably just didn't want to wait.
So I'll just start with an explainer for
who some of these new characters are, so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet,
starting with this guy right here, The
Reader. He's only appeared in the more
recent comics, but he has the ability to
make
whatever he wants to real. So it seems
like his TV version is going to be a
little bit different from the comic book
version.
Right now the only powers we've seen him
manifest are teleportation that might be the
extended his powers in the TV show.
Sometimes when they take characters out of the comics, they'll simplify their powers just because
they'd either be to be too outlandish or too ridiculous or too expensive to do on screen.
So unless we get some different
information I'm just gonna call this guy
a de-powered version of
The Reader. The other really big
character was one of the heads of HYDRA,
the Baroness.
In the comics, she's the wife of the
younger Baron Zemo, the most recent
Baron Zemo. I know it gets a little
confusing but Baron Zemo is a title
that just get passed down, from father to
son.
There's a lot of rumors that we might
see Baron Zemo in Captain America: Civil War
but don't expect to see him on the TV
show. It seems like most of them were
taken out by the end of the episode so,
I'm not expecting to see a whole lot
from her in the future.
That was a pretty badass away to end the episode. High-fives to Coulson.
So let's just go and get started with my top
5 moments, starting with number 5:
Inhumans flashback. We get to see Skye's
mother again and learn a little bit
about what her role was
inside the Inhuman society. As far as
we know they're only a single group of people.
I mean there could be pockets of them
all over the Earth, but this character is
just a younger version of The Reader, the character that shows up at the end of the
episode to save Raina.
The last time we saw Skye's mother, she
didn't have much of a speaking part but
the way they show her off here make it seem like she was actually really important,
like, she'd been around for a long time
and had been helping induct new members into
their society.
That means they probably have more crystals on reserve if they're able to pick and
choose who they introduced to the mists.
I like the Star Wars vibe that it gave off
too, like 'he is young enough to accept the training,
to learn new things, he'd be able to
adjust.' It makes me wonder
if they're gonna create anymore new Inhumans this season.
I'm not expecting them to just because
it seems like now they're going to be
dealing with Raina and Skye developing
their powers and
learning about the society. So one
thing at a time, but the door's open
and they're not gonna close it. So there will
be more new Inhumans eventually.
Moving on to number 4: meet the
heads of HYDRA. The biggest names dropped
were obviously Baron von Strucker,
who we know it's going to be in Age of Ultron, and the Baroness.
For the most part, they're all gone but
if you remember the end of Winter Soldier,
I was actually just re-watching it the other
night, Baron von Strucker, at the end to that
says 'we'll feed then the other HYDRA
selves to keep them of our sent'
Like Baron von Strucker doesn't give a crap about the rest of HYDRA,
he just wants to the continue his experiments with the Mind Gem. I'll be really
interested to see if they'd
try and tie the Mind Gem, like Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch,
Baron von Strucker's experiments, to the Inhumans and their powers
but as of right now, like in the comics
they're definitely very separate things.
The movies tend to simplify things a lot
so I don't know how to explain that
logic, so we'll just to wait for Age of Ultron to come out.
Onto number 3: Coulson puts on a
stage play to get the head of HYDRA
to take themselves out.
I vaguely recall call Coulson or someone
else making a joke about HYDRA biting
its own heads off last year.
I don't know if that actually
happened but in my head I feel like it did.
That's basically what they did: perfectly
pulled off, I mean the pacing in this
episode was great.
and this plan is the best example that.
Moving on to number 2:
Raina is super pissed. What have we
become? I was surprised at how mad she was.
Now part of me thinks that she's
gonna try and turn that group of
Inhumans against Skye. I explained it a little bit at the end of the Inhumans video
that I posted earlier today but
Raina and Skye are like two sides of the same coin. Raina has been running towards
her heritage her whole life, Skye has been
running away.
They both founded it, but in a cruel twist
of fate. Raina did not get exactly what she wanted.
Like her wish was granted in a very evil
way, which is why that last scene was
really important because
The Reader who rescued her says 'hello
beautiful'. So I think
that only is the birth of a new ship. The rest of the season for her
we'll be learning to embrace her new
appearance. It's the same thing with Mystique and
her appearance. It's about learning to be
comfortable in your own skin.
So to speak. I will be really interested to see if Raina tries to go after Skye
because as she said, she feels Skye took
what was rightfully hers, her birthright.
although that's not how terrigenesis
works. Whenever Inhumans undergo terrigenesis,
it just unlocks their genetic
potential.
So Raina was always going to look like
that it had nothing to do with Skye being there.
There's no definitive explanation as to
why some people undergo physical
transformations
and why some people look the same. Part of the reason I think is because comic book
writers and comic book artist just what
people that look really badass.
But another side effect is that
sometimes, when a a mutant like an X-Men mutant,
for example like ,
undergoes terrigenesis, it will make the
powers that they already have
much more powerful or very
unpredictable. So
if someone already had superpowers and they took in the mist, and they had
Inhuman gene, they may just get really
crazy versions and the powers they
already have.
I don't think they're gonna deal with that too much just because it feels like it would
unnecessarily complicate the plot line and
they're just now introducing the idea
of what Inhumans are. Speaking of which
my number one WTF moment: Hail Mary saved by The Reader.
So rewind all the way back to the
midseason finale he was the guy in the
post credit sequence.
When the terrigen crystal went off
that activated Raina and Skye's powers,
it signaled another one where he was,
wherever they're little community is.
Based on the way his powers work, I'm
guessing that whenever a new Inhuman
manifest, and like
they're crystal alarm goes off, its
his job to go out and grab them bring
them into the fold.
This is where things get really
interesting because I think that their
group is going to be relatively neutral
it'll be like the Inhumans in the comics
relative to the Avengers and the other teams.
So for instance, Black Bolt with the
Illuminati fights the Avengers
but that doesn't mean that all of the
Inhumans are totally in love with everyone
else on Earth.
There's a lot of parallels now between
this show and Avengers: Age of Ultron because
we haven't met Scarlet Witch or Quicksilver, I mean obviously the Avengers will
meet them for the first time in the
movie,
but it will not be a very friendly
first meeting, so
I think the same situation will go down
on the show. Like the first time tea,
Coulson meets team Inhumans,
there'll be a small fight, but they're not a bad group of people so
eventually they'll probably reconcile and fight whoever the big vilain on turns out to be the
back half of the season.
They claim Whitehall is dead but we didn't
see is body burn and he has a healing factor
I'm expecting him to resurface at some
point. Part of me kinda hopes that he took in
the mist but I think he already has his Inhuman power
because he stole them from
Skye's mom. Edward James Olmos is gonna
be a really big character but
I don't think that he's going to be the big villain, but Hydra
Baron von Strucker, still very much present in this universe.
Here's my big question for you guys: who do you think the big villain is gonna be
for the second half of the season? Do you
think that Whitehall is gonna come,
you know, with like crazy Inhuman
powers, or do you think that Raina is just gonna go nuts?
I know I already mention it but there's the
whole Mockingbird-Mack plot with like that
little mini RC version of Lola. They said
they were looking for
Fury's toolbox that's the little black
box that Nick Fury gave Coulson last season.
It's a massive hard drive of secrets, so no
idea what they're using it for but I
don't think they're HYDRA,
they're not evil. But until we learn
more, most of my focus is going to be on
the Inhuman stuff.
I think by the end of the season, you
know, whatever their side plot is, it'll
tie back to the Inhumans.
But for now they're two completely
separate things, so most of our attention should just be
on Skye and Raina and what's going on with them. You should also be really excited becase
stuff on the TV show will slowly lead-up
into what's going on
in Age of Ultron. I mean it'll be a softer
crossover then Winter Soldier just because
SHIELD isn't as big a deal in the Age
of Ultron universe.
The producers did confirm though that the
ramifications of
Age of Ultron won't be as Earth-shattering
is the ramifications of Winter Soldier
just because SHIELD came crashing down in that movie. I think I already mentioned it
in Inhumans video earlier today
but there's a new Age of Ultron today,
new Avengers trailer, coming on Thursday
be sure to subscribe to get that. I'll post my break down after it drops but I'm
also probably gonna do a bonus video for
Age of Ultron too.
So if you have any special requests, leave them now. While you guys wait for that stuff, you can click
for a refresher on the origin story, the Inhumans in the comics
and you can click here for all of my Age of Ultron videos.
Thank you so much watching, so let's all
high-five, I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Let's do the thing.